Shen: My name
is Shawn Shen.
I'm a developer advocate
out of Google.
I appreciate
everyone coming.
During lunchtime,
especially.
I think we have
another session.
Great news about Wave.
Google walk around technology.
So they're
making big waves,
but we're interested
in making money here.
Here with me
is Chewy Trewhella from--
he's also a Google
developer advocate from UK.
And we're gonna enjoy
his beautiful British accent
and his beautiful humor.
And also Gerardo Capiel
from Myspace.
He's a vice president
of Platform--
Open Platform
at Myspace.
And previously...
So he--
so he founded...
Most recently he founded
a company called Gydget.
And previously
he was a co-founder
of a public company called
Digital Impact.
So we're gonna
have him to share
some of the greater
experiences
in this social
application space,
best practices,
and he's gonna review
some of the revenue models--
how to make money.
Well, I'm having
a great time here at I/O.
I'm sure you guys
are having a great time too
because yesterday when
I was doing the usual things,
meeting people,
having a great time,
and all of a sudden
I saw everybody
having a little white box.
And everybody is getting
a Magic G2 phone.
So I went downstairs--
I wanted to get one for myself--
and then I was told that
as a Google I don't get one.
Dang.
And you guys
are having a great time.
Not only that--
on Ebay, I see that people
are selling the G phone
for $650 already.
So I'm sure
people are happy
because you guys
are making a profit already.
In my experience working as
a developer advocate at Google,
I have the honor
and privilege
of working with
a lot of developers.
Developers who are not only
talented in writing
applications,
but also very, you know,
smart businessmen.
And we're gonna--
in this talk, we're gonna look
at many great applications
in social space.
You're gonna be amazed how many
ingenious ways people devise
in order to make
your users pay you,
and how to monetize
your application.
So that's what
this is about.
In the end, we're gonna show you
how much money we can make.
So as I was thinking about
everybody getting a G phone,
I was not getting one.
But we're Google,
so we're supposed to do no evil.
And I was thinking,
how can we top that?
How can we make this talk
even better than a G2?
The title is "How To Build
A Business With Social Apps."
I figured that
I'd change the title
to "How to Make a Million Bucks
with Social Applications."
so that's our goal,
you know,
to show some ways
how to make a lot of dollars.
So this is a profile
of a fellow developer.
Some 30 years ago when
he was out there, you know,
writing his code,
most people thought that
sharing of information would
lead to innovation in software.
And this developer,
he insisted
everybody should pay him
for his software.
And in doing that,
he basically created
this commercial software
industry as we know today.
And we know who he is now.
He's the most fam--
the richest guy in the world,
Mr. Bill Gates.
The point I'm trying to drive
here is that sky's the limit.
How much money
are we gonna make?
Well, we're gonna
find out.
In 30 years,
we're gonna find out--
probably from this crowd--
some billionaires
out of many great projects
that we're gonna do.
So here's the agenda
we're gonna talk about today.
Most people are probably
Web application developers.
We are familiar
with typical Web applications.
So we're gonna
talk about it first.
What are the benefits
of taking your Web application
to a social arena,
and what are the advantages
of doing that?
And then Chewy is gonna talk
about the landscape
of social applications.
And Gerardo will cover
the revenue models--
various ways you can make money,
and Chewy will come back
to talk about, you know,
costs, and operations.
And Gerardo will cover--
share some of the best
practices in this space.
And then finally I will
come back to share with you
some of the numbers
that we see in this industry.
And it really show you
how much money
you can make if you have
a small application,
or a medium application,
or really a big blockbuster hit
like a big application.
And hopefully
with all that information,
and I'm sure a lot of you
have some great ideas out there,
you can combine
with the things that we have--
the technologies that we have--
together with your great ideas,
and then you can go out
and make some money.
One thing
I forgot to mention
is that we have
a Google Moderator tool.
So you can enter questions--
Let me go back.
I forgot to mention that.
At the bottom here,
that tiny URL,
you can enter questions
during the session,
and at the end
we'll take the questions,
and you can also
vote on these questions.
But I guess it's much more fun
to not keep your heads down,
and let's talk about
numbers and dollars.
Okay, so just imagine that
we want to start a business.
Easy way is, like,
to set up a lemonade stand.
We need to have
customers that'll pay us
to generate revenue.
and then there's
the associated cost.
The difference between
revenue and cost is your profit.
In doing a Web application,
we're gonna cover
all these areas later.
Revenue, cost...
In doing your Web application,
one key problem we face,
the key challenge is that,
how do we get
all these customers, right?
In a real
brick and mortar business,
that's what you face.
In a Web application
that's also the challenge
that you typically face.
How do we get customers?
Well, imagine that we have
a lemonade stand.
And if one day President Obama
shows up at your stand,
you know how much traffic that's
gonna bring to your stand.
All that foot traffic
would probably convert
into some kind of sales.
So one way to do this--
to get customers--
is to take your lemonade stand
maybe to Mr. Obama.
In our case, I'm gonna
touch on, you know,
what is the thing
that is sort of equivalent
to somebody with star power?
The other disadvantage
of a typical
brick and mortar business
is that you have to do
the sales pitch over and over.
And you also have to--
to make a real ongoing business
you have to build
one stand at a time.
You have one stand,
you have to keep doing it,
and you'll scale it
up to 1,000 stands.
You know, after all,
you have to deliver real goods.
You have to sell
real lemonade.
Is there a better
mouse trap out there?
That's what we're
trying to propose.
Social applications.
Take your Web application
and move into social arena,
and you have
a much better mouse trap.
So here's a picture
you see...
That ring of people
represents social networks.
In the middle there
is the OpenSocial technology.
So if you take
your Web application
to a social arena
with social networks,
what you gain
is millions of users,
and those users,
they also have their friends,
so you have the friend raft.
What they'll do
for you is that
they'll use the inherent
communication channels
afforded by
the social networks,
and inside your application,
as they play and be engaged
with the application,
they're gonna basically
spread the words for you.
So in doing that,
you don't have to
do the sales pitch yourself
over and over.
And also we have open
technologies like OpenSocial
that allows you
to build your application
against one
social network.
And then you can
pretty much
just build it once
and use it everywhere.
Deploy it to multiple
social networks.
We have some
great applications
that are running
on two-dozen social networks.
And we also have--
which is not covered here--
technology like
Google App Engine
that allows you
to scale the back end
from one server
to potentially 1,000 servers
if you have
millions of hits every day.
And these are the things
that help you
to grow your business
really fast.
With that I'm gonna turn to
Chewy, who's gonna cover the--
do a quick survey
of the landscape
of social applications.
Trewhella: Thanks, Shawn.
[mic thumps]
Ah, there we go.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Chewy. I'm from the UK.
I get very excited
when I talk,
and I'll probably end up
speaking very, very quickly,
so if I'm going
too quickly for anyone,
just throw something at me.
I'll dodge it, and that's my cue
to slow down a little bit.
We're gonna talk a little bit
about some of the areas
you can work on
in OpenSocial.
One of the cool things
about OpenSocial
is you can build an application,
and with the same bit of code,
or at least a very
similar piece of code,
you can deploy it
to multiple social networks.
So whatever application
you're building,
you can get it out,
you can get it to a number
of different people.
If you have a look
at opensocial.org
there's a list
of all the social networks
that are currently
supported.
And here's a list
of some of them.
Myspace, Orkut, LinkedIn,
and obviously there's Facebook.
They're not OpenSocial,
but they're a kind of
the elephant in the room
as far as OpenSocial
are concerned.
If you're thinking about
building an OpenSocial
application,
you really have to
look at them.
They've got so many users,
it would be rude not to, right?
The Facebook Developer Platform
is obviously pretty robust.
They developed
their own language,
but the thinking
was with OpenSocial,
rather than every platform
develop their own language,
and leave developers going,
"Oh, which platform
do I develop for?"
We created
a standardized language,
which we then handed out
to a foundation,
the OpenSocial Foundation,
which has standardized this
for use across any network
which would like to support it.
There are a bunch of app
developers out there too
who are building
OpenSocial applications
and Facebook applications
right now.
I don't know if you guys
attended the Fireside Chat
yesterday.
I didn't, but I heard that the
hot topic was virtual currency.
It seems like users
on social networks
are pretty happy
to use virtual currency
but Gerardo's gonna talk a bit
more about that in his section.
You also want to think
about payment providers.
If you're not gonna be using
the built-in virtual currency
you're gonna need to work out
a transaction somehow.
Unless you're happy to set up
your own banking and merchant
and payment
and clearance system,
which you're probably not,
you're gonna want to be looking
at an existing provider.
It could be PayPal,
it could be Google Checkout,
it might be a little bit
more integration
with something
like DataCash or Netpay
or any of the guys
that you can see here.
And then you're gonna
want to look at tools
to measure the success
of your application.
Again, you might want
to use some free tools.
We've got Website Optimizer
and Google Analytics,
which will let you do
a certain amount
of monitoring
and testing for free.
But there are
paid for applications,
which may deliver more
or better results for you.
So these are things you want
to be thinking about too.
Now, which application
should you build?
I guess that's
the biggest question.
This is the eCPM for different
types of applications.
Gerardo's gonna
talk a little more
about exactly
how that's calculated,
but it's essentially
the cost per thousand views
if you're just running
an AdSense-type model.
You can see that card games
are probably the most valuable,
Followed quickly by MMOs.
I guess Warcraft has really
helped drive awareness of those.
And it goes down and down,
so if you want to make
a racing game versus pets,
or a green application, or just
something that's information,
they're gonna be worth less,
but the maintenance,
the security,
the work you're gonna have to do
is less in conjunction
with that.
You know, think about
building a poker game.
The first thing people are gonna
do is try and cheat that system.
They're gonna
try and break it,
they're gonna try
and get the high score,
and get payouts
where they don't
necessarily want them.
Whereas if you're just providing
a customized news feed,
people aren't really motivated
to try and hack that to death.
You might still get people
trying to take it apart,
but it's not gonna be
as serious if it breaks.
So it gives you an idea
of where to focus.
Gerardo's gonna have a look
at this Mouse Hunt app
in a bit more detail
and talk
about things like
what can be bought,
do people pay real dollars,
and how to implement.
But I just wanted to give
a quick overview.
There's a Mouse Hunt game
that's available,
and the idea is you're
a mouse hunter for a kingdom,
and you've just
got to catch mice.
And you use different cheese
to bait them,
and the goal is to be the best
mouse catcher in the kingdom
and get to the top
of the high score charts.
So in order to answer
some of those questions,
here's Gerardo.
Capiel: Thank you.
All right.
Let's talk about making money
with OpenSocial.
So there's a bunch of different
avenues that you can take
to generate revenues
from your social application.
You can do advertising,
you can build a virtual economy,
you can build branded apps,
and then there's
a number of other techniques
that I'll dive into.
So let's talk
about advertising,
which is probably
the best-known technique,
probably
the oldest technique
with making money
on social applications.
So for advertising you can run
either display or text link ads
and then charge for those on
a CPM basis, CPI, or CPA basis.
One of the more
popular ways
of making money
with social applications today
is actually advertising other
peoples' social applications.
And in that type of case,
you tend to get paid
on a cost per install,
so some other
application provider
that wants to promote
their application
that knows
that your user base
is obviously
application users--
a very nicely
targeted base--
is gonna pay you on a cost
per install, and that ranges--
you know, it could be
as low as 75¢
all the way up to,
let's say, $2.
So implementing advertising
is also the easiest thing to do
in terms of generating revenue
with your social application.
It's simply cutting and pasting
some JavaScript code
in either case here.
So pretty easy
to implement.
So it's easy,
but there are challenges.
Can't--if it was--
And one of the challenges is
that eCPMs have been declining.
That is a function
of the economy,
where there's less demand,
it's also
a function of supply,
so there are a lot
of social applications
out there right now,
a lot of inventory.
So it's harder today
than it used to be
to actually monetize
your application
purely through advertising,
and a lot of the successful
companies in this base--
advertising is only
a small fraction
of their total revenue.
But, that said,
the key to it
is to be contextually
relevant with your ads.
So if you're developing
an application around music,
then you should be focusing
on ads around ring tones,
which tend to pay
pretty well,
music downloads,
and concert tickets.
All right, so let's shift to
a different way to make money,
which is by creating a virtual
economy with your game,
and this is
actually probably
one of the hottest
areas right now.
It's a space, it's about
a year and a half old,
but there are companies
that are already building,
rumors are, 100 million-dollar
businesses a year
based on, primarily,
virtual economies.
And to illustrate this,
let's talk about
this Mouse Hunt app game,
where your goal
is to catch mice.
And you can catch mice
by actually having
cheese and traps.
But you got to buy the cheese
and traps to catch the mice.
And you do that
through a virtual currency
that they--let's just
generically call it gold.
So to get gold--
you can actually do things
in the game to get gold,
but if you want
to go the fast way,
which is what happens
with a large enough
percentage of people,
you can buy the gold.
So buying the gold is enabled
through a payment provider.
PayPal is a very common
payment provider,
but there are about a dozen
that I can probably name
off of the top of my head
in terms of payment providers
that are out there.
And in this case
they're just taking
direct payments
through a credit card.
There are some providers
that actually allow you
to bill--to charge your users
using a mobile phone,
using premium SNS,
but primarily credit card
is the main form
of direct payment,
and like I said,
PayPal is a big provider.
And here what you're seeing
from a revenue standpoint
is anywhere from $1 to $10
per daily active user.
So let's say your users don't
want to pay with a credit card.
Well, there are other ways that
you can actually monetize these,
and using virtual currency.
And this is kind of a hybrid
between advertising
and direct payment.
And here what you're doing
is you're actually
giving gold to users
when they fill out offers.
and who you're gonna get paid by
is the offer provider.
So it could be like Netflix
that's actually gonna pay you--
let's say--I'm just
gonna pick a number,
this is not actually
a realistic number--
but let's say they'll
pay you $30 for every user
that you get
to fill out an offer
and sign up
for a Netflix subscription.
And so here
the way this works
is when a user wants
to get some gold,
they are presented
with a set of offers,
they choose which offer
they want to pick--
there are numerous providers
in the offer space--
they fill out the offer,
and then the offer provider
pays you,
and actually you give
the user the currency.
And so one company
in this space, for example,
is OfferPal that provides
this type of functionality,
here the average revenue
per 100 DAUs is about $7.50.
So it's a pretty
lucrative area as well.
Implementation is just
a little bit harder.
obviously you've got
to build a whole concept
of virtual currency
into your application.
But to integrate
the payment providers
is pretty easy.
You're essentially gonna bring
an iframe into your application
that's bringing in all the
offers from the offer provider,
in this case OfferPal,
and then you're gonna
implement on your server
some code to actually
handle a callback
that OfferPal
is gonna do to tell you
that the transaction
was completed, who it was,
and how much currency you should
be giving to that person.
So pretty easy
in terms of implementation.
Probably the hardest part
is to figure out
how to create that
virtual economy in your game.
So let's talk about
a third way to make money,
which is by creating
branded applications.
Now this approach
is not--
We haven't seen it
as much here in the U.S.,
but it's pretty popular,
particularly in Europe
and in Asia,
and some examples of brands
that have been involved in this
are Coke, Sony Ericsson,
Heineken.
I'm gonna show you
a few examples here.
One great example
is FooPets,
where they actually
integrated a dog food brand
very nicely into the game
so the users don't feel like
they're really being hard sold.
So here's an example--
an application
that is featuring Coca Cola.
Coke sponsored
this application.
The application includes
ways to share and send
virtual colas to your friends,
or weekly prizes,
there's an area for users
to submit input
and write their own stories.
Here's the FooPets example,
where, you know,
you can buy your pet some food.
and you're gonna buy them
Purina Puppy Chow food.
So very subtly integrated--
or not so subtle--into the game.
Appssavvy is a company
that's out there
that if you were a developer
or you're a brand,
they can connect developers
and brands together.
So those are kind of the three
probably most popular one--
methods of making money.
There's a few other techniques
that are out there.
One is to create an app
where it's free to use
in the beginning.
Like, for example, Box.net.
But as you start to require
more storage, let's say,
in this application
where you're storing files,
they're gonna
charge you for that,
so it's a premium
model here.
There's also donation
type of revenue models,
where essentially people
are donating money to a cause.
A cause is a very
popular example.
You can also make money
by building custom applications
for other companies.
And then the last
way here--
and this is really
in the early phases of this,
but we are seeing
some third party applications
developing special relationships
with social networks
and then getting
featured placement,
and in return
they're doing revenue share
with those companies.
It's kind of a long shot
probably for most companies,
but it does exist
out there
for companies
that have something
really compelling
for a social network.
that they want to
integrate in.
So with that,
let me turn it back to Chewy
to talk about cost.
Trewhella:
Are we on? Yay. Okay.
So how many people
have run their own business
at one time or another?
I have; before I was at Google,
I ran quite a lot of businesses
or worked
at small companies.
Obviously none of them
hugely successful
or I'd be on a yacht
in the Caribbean
as opposed to onstage
talking to you.
But one of the things
that almost always
tripped me up was cost.
It's something you've got to
keep in the back of your mind.
Cost is broadly broken up
into five areas,
at least for the purpose
of this presentation.
We've got development,
so actually, you know,
building the thing,
getting people into code
and design stuff.
Hosting and operations.
Where does the thing live,
what does it live on?
Shawn's talked
a little bit about that,
but I'm gonna go
into some more detail.
You've got marketing
and advertising costs.
I'd love to be able to say
that you're gonna get
a bajillion users and make
a bajillion dollars
without spending
a penny on--
or I guess a cent on making
people aware of your app,
but that's not really
the case anymore.
You are gonna have to invest
something into that.
Community management.
Once you get
a bunch of users,
you're gonna need
to support those users.
There are some ways you can
save cash around doing that,
and we'll have a look
at those too.
And then finally others.
I guess one of
the most important in there
is, like, legal and office.
And we'll talk about
some of those too.
So first of all,
development.
I'm guessing,
or at least I'm hoping
everyone's hand'll go up
when I say this.
How many developers
are in the room?
Yeah, okay, how many
non-developers in the room?
Okay, a few.
That's all right.
We won't bite.
But as a developer you've
probably worn many, many hats.
You've probably
been a developer,
you may at one time or another
have tried to design stuff.
If you're anything like me,
you'll have realized
very quickly that you can't.
It's funny,
I know more designers
who can do a bit of code
than coders
who can do
a bit of design.
Maybe that's just
my group of friends.
But when you're
developing this product,
it may be a simple app
that only requires you.
And you may just
need some icons
that you can source
from creative commons,
and use Microsoft Paint
to knock up
some basic graphics and convert
into pngs or whatever,
but chances are
you're gonna need
to invest in a designer
at some point.
And also,
once your team grows,
if it becomes a really
big application,
you're gonna need someone
to manage these costs.
Now with development
of any code--
I was having a chat with
a couple of people last night,
and we were saying
there's an 80-20-80 rule.
I don't know how many
of you have heard this.
You probably know it
even if you haven't heard it
explained like this.
And it's the idea
that 80% of the development
will take 80%
of the time,
and the last 20% will take
another 80% of the time.
Because you're, you know,
you get nearly there,
and then you're like,
"Oh, what if we just moved that?
"And hey, that bit
doesn't work.
And oh, we just need
to change that around."
Feature creep--what if we
added this element?
So think about that too.
But one of the things also
to think about is iterate often.
At Google we roll stuff out.
It's why we have the beta tag
on so many products.
But we want to get
stuff out there,
and we want to see
how people are using it.
And I've seen
big organizations
that I've talked to
crippled by meetings.
They want to get
everything perfect,
so they wait a year and a half
before launching something,
by which time it's
kind of obsolete anyway,
especially on the Internet,
and especially
in social networking.
So think about creating
a small feature set
that solves a real problem,
get it out the door quickly,
see what users think, and then
iterate, fix it, update.
Here's an example
of an application from iGoogle.
It just shows a really nice way
to solve a user problem.
All of you have probably
at one time or another
needed to search
online for travel.
If you just know that you
want to visit a friend--
Let's say
I'm in San Francisco
and I've got a friend
in L.A.,
and I want to visit them
sometime in June.
I don't necessarily
want to search 34 or 30 times--
31 times for all
the different days
to find
the cheapest flight.
I install this gadget,
and I say I want to travel
from here to here
in this month--Save.
And then I don't know
if you can see it,
but the cheapest flights
are outlined in yellow.
And every time I come back
or reload this page,
that's gonna do
a real-time search
and show
the cheapest dates.
And so instead of me
having to, you know,
go and do these
searches every day
or subscribe
to something,
I just stick this gadget
on my homepage
and it's giving me
the information I want.
It's kind of like
a personal search agent,
if that's what you want
to think about.
This doesn't necessarily
make a lot of sense socially,
but these are the sort of things
you want to be thinking about.
Does this solve user need?
Does this do something
users are gonna
find useful
and want to engage with?
Next, hosting
and operations.
Does everyone know
what "LAMP" stands for?
Okay, a few don't.
It's Linux, Apache,
MySQL, and PHP.
It's just a name for a kind of
server with some software on it.
It could be Windows, IIS,
SQL Server, and .Net,
but WISN is probably
not as easy to say.
I mean, it could be Linux,
Apache, Postgres, and JSP,
but again, LAPJ doesn't really
make a lot of sense.
The point is it's
having some servers
with some software on
that you manage.
Either you own those servers
or you're leasing them
in a data center somewhere.
And that's gonna have
a cost associated with it.
Not only the cost of actually
hiring the hardware,
but then you're gonna need
sys admin skills.
You're gonna need
to make sure
that your server software
is patched.
I don't know how many of you
went to Matt Cutts's talk
about building
a good Web site,
but one of the points
he made was, you know,
Web sites now--it's PCs.
Home PCs become more secure
as people switch to Apple,
as Windows 7 rolls out,
as people are starting
to use Linux.
The hackers are going
off the Web sites
because they're
easier to attack.
People don't necessarily patch
Apache to the latest version,
and then there'll be
vulnerabilities.
So if you're running
your own servers,
you need to make sure
they're up to date.
And there's a cost there too.
Don't forget about that cost.
Joyent and Sun off
a kind of hosted platform.
That's scalable, that runs
for free for very low usage
up to cost once you start
to get a bit of traffic,
and it's on demand, so you can
scale them up and down.
Some of you may know
of Amazon EC2.
They basically let you
rent machines--virtual machines,
and you build
an image and install it,
but again you'll need
to think about sys admin
and patching
and all that good stuff.
They recently launched,
I think last week, on the 18th,
a system that allows you
to auto-scale based on demand,
so they just deploy
new servers as you need it.
But you're still having to
provision the software yourself.
Now I don't want
to sit here and go,
"Well, Google have got
the solution for you,"
'cause that's not
what this is about,
but if I were
a developer in this age,
I'd be looking at App Engine
or something similar
pretty seriously.
Because App Engine lets you
focus just on the software.
You build the software,
Google takes care
of scaling it up and down.
And remember,
with social applications,
things can go viral
very quickly.
You get a few key people
who are interested in your app,
they tell their friends,
and suddenly bang,
you've got a million users,
it can happen.
Here's a graph of growth.
It's pretty simplistic, but it
should give you a basic idea.
If you're using a LAMP stack,
if you're renting machines,
your machines are gonna
be good to a certain point,
and then you're gonna need
to deploy additional ones.
So you're really gonna see
this step growth graph.
And something
to think about there
is if load
diminishes over time,
how do you take
those servers offline?
You're still gonna
be paying rental,
and chances are
you're gonna be
in for a minimum
contract period.
So think carefully
about buying new servers.
EC2 lets you scale
a little more smoothly.
You can switch them
on and off as load requires.
App Engine's a slightly
smoother graph.
I don't want to sit here
and push App Engine,
but because you're just
focusing on process,
you're literally only
paying for what you use.
The other advantage
of App Engine is you'll get
up to five million page views
a month for free.
So they'll let you experiment
with different services
and see if your
business is viable
before you actually have to
start paying hosting costs.
There are a bunch
of talks on App Engine
if you want to learn more,
and there's some
office hours happening
if you really want
to play grab the SDK,
have a knock around, that's not
what we're here to talk about.
Marketing and advertising.
So advertising.
You've built your application,
you want to get it known.
There's a few ways
to do this.
Obviously AdWords--
paid networks where you can
advertise your application--
but then actually within
the social networks as well.
You can do gallery sponsorship,
as Gerardo mentioned,
there are even some ways
to get your app
sponsored in exchange
for rev share,
you know, get it featured
in gallery listings.
There are app
ad networks too,
so you can advertise
within other apps,
you can advertise
on the social networks,
you can advertise in places
where people would go,
and advertise
in areas where people
actually engage
in what you're doing.
So if you're building
a virtual dog application,
go to pet sites
and say, you know,
if you're thinking
about buying a dog,
why not try the app first to see
if you can look after one?
There's no real, kind of,
you know, parallel to draw,
but people who like dogs
in real life
probably like
virtual dogs too.
So think
about that as well.
Then you've got
organic growth.
So within the social network,
you've got a bunch of mechanisms
for talking to people.
You've got activity streams,
so when someone
installs an application
you can write to that
and advertise the fact.
You've got installing the
application on a user's profile.
You can send invitations out.
But be smart
about sending invitations.
One of the things
that really upsets me
about applications
I see today is I install one,
and it says, "Send an invitation
to all your friends."
Probably most of my friends
aren't gonna like
the same applications
that I do.
And applications
have the ability
to learn about my friends.
Especially in OpenSocial.
I can poll my friends,
learn about their interests,
so if I'm installing
a snowboarding application,
instead of just saying,
"Give this to all my friends,"
why not find out which of my
friends also like snowboarding?
And then intelligently say,
"Hey, we see five of your
friends are also snowboarders,
"do you think they'd
like this app too?
Click here to send
an invite."
It's a lot friendlier,
and users are gonna
feel like your app's
a bit smarter,
and that it's actually something
they'd want to pass on.
And then of course
notifications.
Once you install the app
or do something
You can write to your wall, or
write to your activity stream,
or, you know, send out mails,
or whatever it might be.
But it's not just within
the social network itself.
BuddyPoke is the most popular
application on OpenSocial.
And there's about 3 1/2 thousand
videos on YouTube,
and they're all kind of,
you know, a few thousand views,
but even if each of them
were only 1,000,
that's still, what, 3 1/2
million views of BuddyPoke.
And if you are gonna put videos
of your content up on YouTube,
think about the metadata.
See in the red box? "Buddy Poke,
Buddy Poke, Buddy Poke..."
Sure, if you search for "Buddy
Poke," that's the first result.
Simply because they
cracked the metadata.
But how many people
search for Buddy Poke?
Probably not that many.
Think about what
your application is,
don't just put the name,
but also put the types
of things that it is.
So if it's a virtual pet app,
don't put, you know,
"My V-Pet."
Put "virtual pet."
You know,
"play with your dog online."
Community management.
This is the next one.
So you've got, you know,
100,000 users,
and some of them are gonna
start breaking things,
so you need to think
about security issues.
Some of them are just
gonna be stupid.
You know, users are dumb.
Not every user, but guarantee,
lowest common denominator.
My mom hitting
your application
is gonna click in the wrong
place every single time,
and bookmark places
that you didn't expect
after submitting a form
with something weird
in a query string,
so that when she comes
back to that bookmark
it breaks something.
And it's something
you haven't thought about.
So you're gonna want
to test all this stuff.
But you're also gonna
want to make sure
there's a feedback loop for
your users to report problems.
The cool thing is because
of social networks,
you can actually leverage users
who are using your apps
and recruit power users
to help support.
You know, people who actually
enjoy playing with it
and have a bit
of time to spare
and are really happy
to give their time.
With the inclusion
of virtual currency,
maybe you can reward them.
So with the Mouse Hunt game,
people who are, you know,
happy to support your forums
with users who are
having install issues,
maybe chuck them a few pieces
of gold or a new bit of cheese
every time they help
someone out effectively.
It's a really nice
way to do it,
it's not costing
you anything overtly,
but it's recruiting a great
bunch of people to help you out.
And scale by
leveraging your users.
So also forums.
Where people can actually
post these messages.
Most social networks
will have
a discussion area
that you can use.
But there are things
like Google Groups
where you can set up
free discussion forums too,
if that's what
you want to do.
Now, other costs.
Ad sales.
You've got some ads
running on your application.
Maybe your application's
become so popular
the ad network
you were using
can't actually
deliver inventory.
After a certain point, you know,
ads just stop showing.
So you're gonna
have to either find
a manual
or an automated solution
that lets you switch
ad networks,
possibly multiple times a day,
if your app's really popular.
This is something
to think about early on
so that you're ready
when it happens.
Direct sales force.
Maybe it gets to the point
where you have built
this $100-million app,
and you want to have
a direct sales force
who are ringing people up to
advertise specifically with you.
Again these are costs
you need to think about.
One of the cool things
about salespeople, though,
is they work for commission.
So you can only pay them
if they're really successful.
But it's still gonna be
a cost that's associated.
Rev sharing, partnerships.
If you're using
something like AdSense,
don't forget a chunk
of money
will actually go to
the network providing the ads.
On fixed costs--
office, legal.
So if you're
renting offices,
don't forget rent
is a pretty big deal.
Electricity,
things like that. Tax.
But more importantly
legal costs.
This is a social network
application you're building.
You're gonna be
interacting with user data.
The moment
you start to do that
you want to have
a rock-solid privacy policy.
You want to make it
absolutely clear
what the terms
of service are,
what you're gonna be doing
with peoples' data.
You can try
and write this yourself.
You might be
very successful,
or you might get sued because
you didn't make it clear
what was happening or
the language wasn't appropriate.
One of the best things
you can do early on
is invest a little bit
of money in getting
a rock-solid legal disclaimer
or, you know, terms of service.
From a professional.
Make sure it's
from a professional.
That's absolutely key.
Tracking and optimizing.
So they talked a little bit
about this earlier,
but you want to look
at what your users are doing.
I speak to so many big companies
in the UK and across Europe
who have analytics
tools installed,
and then you say, "Okay, so
how many users are you getting?"
They'll turn around
and go,
"Oh, we don't really know.
We don't look at the data."
You're recording it.
It's there.
That's actually
information
about who's coming
to your Web site.
If you're not looking
at this stuff every single day,
you're missing a trick.
This is a real-time
kind of health check.
Pulse of who's interacting
with your Web site,
or in this case,
your social application.
So record data,
look at it, and react to it.
If people are clicking
on the wrong button,
if they're going through
the wrong path to get somewhere,
it may be the fact that
your users are just clumsy
and don't know
what they're doing,
but it could also be possible
that it's not entirely clear.
You know, we can sometimes
be so close to our apps
that it seems really obvious
what people should be doing.
A user comes in
from nowhere,
clicks on things
that you just didn't expect,
and ends up in a terrible,
terrible mess.
So make sure that you're
monitoring this stuff too.
Also test
different solutions.
At Google, for Google Search,
at any given time,
we have five to ten
experiments
going on for
our search results.
And I think we deployed
something like
250 changes to our
search results last year.
So we're always trying
to tweak
just a little bit
to make things better.
And whenever
you're thinking
about building a Web site
or building an application,
you should be thinking
about this too.
I'm not suggesting you get
that aggressive
with the number of changes,
but I guarantee whatever you
launch isn't the best it can be.
So you should always be
looking for better solutions.
With that said,
we're on to best practices.
Capiel: I think Chewy
mentioned it quite a bit,
and I just want
to really bring this home
that you got to measure
and you got to optimize
what you're doing.
And there's really kind of three
key metrics at a high level
that you're gonna
be looking at.
First is reach,
which is how many people are
you able to reach and acquire?
Then there's retention,
so you've gotten a user
into your application.
How often can you get them
to use the application
and stay in there?
So how often you
get 'em to come back,
and how long
do you keep them for?
And then finally if you do
a great job of those first two,
then I would
highly encourage you
to pay a lot of attention
to the next piece, which is--
okay, I got all these users,
they're coming back,
now how do I turn 'em
into dollars?
And as you can see
from the ranges on this slide,
there tend to be pretty wide
ranges in terms of, you know,
your ability
to convert users,
to acquire them,
and then also your ability
to take users
and make them active users.
And Google Analytics,
by the way,
is a great tool for that.
Looking at bounce rates
on your application is good,
looking at time spent
on your application is good.
Those are key metrics
that you want to look at
in terms of determining
whether you have
a return problem
or an acquisition problem.
So what are the communication
channels that you can use?
Well, Chewy talked
a little bit about those.
There's activity streams,
and there's notifications,
and those depend quite a bit
in terms of the social network
about how they're
actually implemented,
but almost all
the social networks
have those
two basic channels.
The key is,
to these channels--
they can be very powerful,
but they can also be
very detrimental to your app.
Like in the case
of Myspace,
a notification is not only
a way that you can get someone
to reengage with
your application,
but it's also a way
that you can
get 'em to uninstall
your application
if you're spamming them.
So the key to not spam,
or to make your messages
actually relevant
and not perceived as spam,
is to do a lot of testing.
And A/B testing is
a very common technique
where you're gonna be
testing
different types
of dynamic content,
you're gonna test
different types of offers,
different pieces of content
that you consider relevant.
For an A/B test you're gonna
want to typically use
some type of analytics tool.
Kontagent provides
some great analytic tools
for doing A/B testing.
But there's really--
also a lot of people have
homegrown tools,
and you can even use
Google Analytics
for doing some of this.
The interesting thing
about A/B testing
is that everyone
always kind of thinks
what they think
users want to hear,
what they're gonna
react to,
and I guarantee
you, like,
if you looked
at these two messages here,
half of the crowd
would say
the bottom one
is the most successful,
and half the crowd
would say the top.
You just don't know
unless you test things.
So in this example,
these two messages here
had a pretty huge
difference
in terms of conversion
rates.
The other day I was hearing
one of the top application
developers on Myspace
talk about,
and he was saying,
"Don't get discouraged
"if your application growth
is completely flat.
"Just keep tweaking things.
Little things, little things.
"Keep tweaking and measuring
back and forth,
"and you're gonna find
that one little thing
"that actually really
starts to kind of drive
"viral growth
in your application,
and then hopefully
also retention."
So the other thing is
it's not only gonna be
in the messaging that you
want to do your A/B testing,
it's gonna be with what
revenue sources you're using.
So you're gonna want
to do A/B testing
on whether I should
use direct payment,
whether I should charge people
directly with credit cards,
or whether I should
present offers.
And then even
within offers,
you're gonna want
to be doing A/B testing
to actually determine, of all
the companies that are out there
that provide offer
solutions,
which ones convert
the best for my audience?
And that's really gonna
depend,
from application
to application,
which--
which offer provider--
which payment provider
works best
is gonna be very different
because every application
has a very different audience.
And a great tool is--
Symmetrix has some great tools
for doing that as well.
So the most
successful applications
that we're seeing across
the social networks are games,
particularly on Myspace.
Games have done
very, very well.
I think not every application
has to be a game,
and not every one of you better
say, once I develop a game,
but I would highly
encourage you to take a look
at the design patterns that
the game providers are using
because they've become
very smart about this
in terms of the ways
that they get people
to re-engage
with the applications
by using leaderboards,
leveling up, point systems.
Providing kind of
special offers that are--
that are available--
every day there's a new offer
that's available.
These are all techniques
that any application
can really
take advantage of.
And here's
a great quote from--
I'm guessing it's
from Dan Yue over at Playdom--
in terms of what--
how they look at things.
They don't assume anything,
as I was saying.
They measure
and test everything,
and that's--that's how they
listen to their customers.
And community boards,
by the way,
are also a great way
to listen to your customers.
They're just typically
not as quantitative.
They're a little bit more
qualitative in nature.
So that's it.
I'll let Shawn kind of wrap up
with some great stats.
Shen: Thank you.
Okay, so,
ready for some numbers.
Let's look at some stats
from within the industry,
how much money
we can make.
It's estimated
that this space--
it's been only around for, like,
almost just two years,
and estimated revenue
stands around,
like, more than
$1/2 million.
Anywhere from $500
to 700 million.
A lot of developers
out there--
about the top ten
developers--
they account
for almost 2/3 of the revenue.
The big ones
that Chewy mentioned earlier,
they account for, like,
2/3 of the total revenue.
In terms of revenue split,
you can see that ads
estimated to be 20%.
The middle part,
which is the virtual
economy-based models,
they account for
a huge portion of it.
Yesterday
at the Fireside Chat,
if you guys heard
from the developers,
most of them are heavily
moving into that area.
Between direct pay, which is,
like, credit card or PayPal,
and then offers,
is about a 40/30% split.
And the rest of it
is about 10%.
To that regard,
because we have this huge
interest in virtual economy,
there are two exciting news
in OpenSocial
that I'd like
to just mention.
One is hi5
that they recently used--
this virtual currency API
and OpenSocial technology,
and they implemented
a network-wide hi5 coin.
The advantage of having
a network-wide coin--
currency is that
developers--
they can just hook into it
using some standard API,
and right away
their application will be able
to support payment
and transactions.
And from the user's
standpoint,
there is a very good advantage
of trust because, like,
a lot of the
international markets--
Brazil, you know, hi5
in Latin American countries,
users--they are not really
comfortable paying
any developer that they
don't have any idea about.
So if you provide
a hi5 coin,
right away people say,
"Okay, I'm paying hi5,
I can trust that."
The transaction's
a lot smoother.
And the first application
that's done by RockYou--
and they have
a Sandbox booth here
if you want
to talk with them--
This is the first
application
that they did this
integration with hi5 coins.
The next one is Cyworld.
We announced that Cyworld
is gonna support OpenSocial.
They have their Sandbox
open already.
Some of the developers
are working with them.
I'd just like to
call out that we have
two representatives
from Cyworld here,
so if you guys want
to come to talk with them later,
please feel free.
Also I'd like to take
this opportunity to mention
that Hyves from Europe,
they are also here, right?
And if you guys are interested
in talking with them,
they are very much
like a Dutch--
like a Netherland-focused
social network.
Very active user base.
So if you're interested
in talking with them,
please go to them
after the talk.
Earlier we also
mentioned
there are various other
providers in the space.
Symmetrix is one, Analytics,
and also Optimization Company.
They have a Sandbox
demo booth out there,
so feel free to go
to talk with them.
This is some screenshots
that I took from Cyworld.
Cyworld has been a pioneer
in this space for ten years.
They basically pioneered
this virtual economy-based model
along with some of
the great Chinese companies.
It's really popular in China,
as you can see on the screen.
There is the mini room
that you can set up,
and then you can buy
all sorts of decorations,
and there is the homepage,
and there is the mini stories
that users can share,
and charge and pay each other.
Okay, so I mentioned
earlier,
from a developer's perspective,
how much money can we make?
So here-this is sort of what
I call a small application.
At the very top
you can see
the number that I got
from Offerpal, for example.
How much money are they paying
out to what they call publisher,
which is really developer?
How much money
are they paying out?
The reported number,
average number,
is about $75 per day
per 1,000 active users.
So if we take
that number--
I try to be conservative,
I only take $25.
If you have an application
that has 10,000 users,
how much money
would that be?
25 x 10,000.
We're talking
about $250 a day.
That's about, say,
$90,000 a year.
In terms of hosting cost,
like Chewy covered,
you probably need,
like, two servers.
One Web server on the front,
and one database server
on the back,
and at $100 apiece,
$200 a month,
we're talking about
$2,400 a year.
So even in a relatively
small application,
the hosting cost
is not a big factor.
Once you have the traffic,
you'll still be
looking at a gross profit
of $80,000.
One person,
you can probably hack away
and create a lot of virtual
world for your happy users.
If you have
a medium-sized application
with, like, 100,000 users,
then we're talking
about serious business
because you're talking
about $2,500 a day,
almost $1 million in revenue--
in gross revenue a year,
and again the hosting cost,
if I give it
a very generous number--
$5,000 a month--
that's still only $60,000
a year.
That still leaves you
a lot of profit.
I put down some
expenses for offices--
$200,000 for just
general expenses--
we're still looking
at $650,000 a year.
You'll probably be able to hire
your own graphic designers,
and quite a few
developers.
If you really have a big hit,
with 1 million active users--
a lot of applications
have that--
then we're talking
about very serious money.
$25,000 a day,
almost $10 million a year.
Hosting cost again
is the smallest,
insignificant part
of the equation.
We're talking about $8.9 million
in gross profit.
We take 2 million
out of expenses,
we are left with $7 million.
So that's the number
we are looking at.
Now I hope I'm getting
your brain really fired up
with your great ideas--
go out and build
some great applications.
So how profitable
is this space?
If I put it in the grand scheme
of things, you know,
we have a lot of big companies
like Yahoo and Google.
These I took some
of the public numbers.
You can just look at the
revenues of Yahoo and Google.
So in the social space
we have--
the market is about
$500-700 million.
On average, across, you know,
all the networks,
there are about 50-70 million
active users daily.
So the payout is anywhere
from 5 to say $12, $15.
Every user is worth
that much every year for you--
every active user.
If you take Yahoo's number,
$7 billion in revenue,
they have about, say,
150 million active users,
their user is worth
about $50 apiece.
And Google is the most
profitable in this metric.
Google has $22 billion,
anywhere from 160
to 200 million users.
Google's user--
every single user is worth $100.
So what this means is that
it took us two years to grow
the virtual economy-based model
of the social applications
to get to the point where
each user is worth, say, $10.
And then the Web portals
has been around for,
what, 15 years,
and each user is $50
to $100.
There's still a lot
of room to grow,
and earlier when Gerardo
shared with you
some of
the revenue models,
there are still a lot
of revenue streams
that can potentially
generate a lot of money.
So I want to leave you guys
with one more example
of applications,
because what I see
is this example
is kind of like a template.
One single developer,
Dave,
he invented this concept
of Mob War.
A lot of people probably
play these kind of games.
And this is actually
a clone of Mob War on Myspace.
Mobster.
As you can see
in this application,
there are things
that I can do.
I can go out
and basically be a mobster,
develop my gang,
and do some jobs.
In this case, like, I was doing
a collection--protection--
collect protection money--
just go out and collect money
for my boss.
If I try to click
the button to the job,
it's gently reminding me
that I'm out of energy.
Or sometimes I need extra item
in order to finish that job.
And I can also go out and buy
properties and earn money.
There are a lot
of things you can do.
But the key here is that
at the very top you can see
there are three
control levels.
There's the energy, health,
and then stamina.
So these are the things you want
to build into your game--
little levels
that will control the pace
that your users can really
engage with your application.
By doing that,
what'll happen is the users--
some users, they want
to really get into the game
and be advanced in levels,
really get into this game,
and they will
buy energy in this case.
They will buy health
when they get hurt
in fighting
with other players.
So a lot of applications
are very much like that.
This is kind of a great template
that you guys can use
to build levels,
control the pace
of the user, their activity,
so they will pay you
in those virtual goods.
So we've talked about
the business opportunity
in the space.
We've covered the landscape
with a brief survey,
and we covered
revenue streams in the space.
We also talked
about the cost side,
and shared some of the best
practices with you guys.
And I hope it's all making
good dollars and sense for you.
And with the great
Mouse Trap--
a lot of great ideas I'm sure
you guys are thinking about.
And combine it
with technology like OpenSocial,
I hope that'll translate
into dollars for you guys.
And if you are
still not convinced
that this is one way
to make money,
and the least I hope
is that
you guys can go out
and be mobsters.
Okay, thank you.
With that...
So this is just attribution
to some of the creative contents
that I used in this talk,
and some great links
we have here
At the bottom,
as you can see, again,
is the Google Moderator tool
that if you have questions,
please submit it
or vote it there.
And with that,
I'll open up for some questions.
We have two mics here,
so please come to the mic
so everybody can hear
the questions.
Thank you.
[applause]
Go ahead.
audience member:
I was wondering whether there is
an opportunity or a place
for a subscription-based
revenue model.
And what would be
the implications for,
for example,
the target market?
More discerning users--
users would like actually
to engage
in specific activity.
How could this
be organized--
in sense of all
the methods
that have been
described here--
work also
for such a model?
Shen:
You want to take that?
So I'm sorry,
I couldn't hear
the last part of
your question.
audience member:
What of the methods
that you have described here
for user retention,
and some of the other methods,
would work also
in the subscription-based
revenue model?
Capiel: Right. So yeah.
So on a subscription model,
obviously it's gonna be
really important
for you to retain
your users as long
as possible.
audience member:
Would you a little bit louder?
I cannot hear at all.
Capiel: Sorry.
I was saying that with
the subscription-based models...
Trewhella:
Is the mic on?
Capiel: It's still
a little early.
We're not seeing--
at least on Myspace
we're not seeing
a monitor's model out there.
I have seen them with some
of the other applications.
I think LinkedIn
might even have one application
that has
a subscription-based model.
Trewhella: Dude, you turned
your mic off, I think.
Capiel: No, it's on.
Well, anyway,
I'll just talk louder.
So it's early to say
with subscription-based models,
but I think
that they will work.
There's a company called
[indistinct], I think it is,
that essentially
provides technology
for companies that want
to develop
subscription-based models
with their applications.
So I don't know if
I've answered your question.
There's not that much
of it out there,
but I think it is an area
that we'll probably
start to see more activity.
Trewhella:
There are, um...
There are also traditional
kind of payment gateways
like DataCash
and Net Pay
that will let you set up
subscription payments
so you can move outside
the social network
to charge the money
that way.
If that's what
you wanted to do.
audience member:
Okay. Thanks.
Shen: Okay. Thank you.
Go ahead.
audience member: Hi.
Chewy, I think,
mentioned...
This is a legal question.
So I guess for the E.U.
there are more restrictive...
there are more restrictions
on privacy and things like that.
How do you sort of--
You don't have control
about who's coming to your site,
so do you simply sort of choose
the most restrictive regime,
or how do you keep
from running afoul of privacy
and laws and things
like that?
Trewhella: I mean,
it's gonna depend
on the network
you're deployed on as well.
So different networks
will have different rules.
But, I mean, you can
set up your users
to agree to a standard ULA
under, say, U.S. law,
and then anyone
who's coming in
is just restricted
by whatever terms you set.
So you don't have to worry
about setting it up
for each country
that everyone might come from.
Because someone
subscribing to your app,
because they're agreeing
to the terms and conditions,
they're agreeing
under the law that you define.
I mean, I'm not a lawyer,
so don't take that as read.
You'll probably want
to confirm that with a lawyer,
but certainly, like,
a lot of our services
will launch in the States,
and people from other
countries can come
as long as they agree
to a U.S. law agreement,
they're free to use them.
[chuckles] We--So, um--
No, it's fine.
For legal--
So if you've got people coming
in from other jurisdictions,
which restrict--
or which privacy laws
do you choose to go with?
Capiel: Um, I mean,
I think you can--
the social network
is gonna have
some pretty clear
guidelines by itself
in terms of,
you know, how--
what privacy constraints
you have to work within.
And usually that social network,
like Myspace,
is operating
in multiple countries.
Then they will have actually
set up a privacy policy
that's applicable
across regions.
So you should be covered,
but that said, you know,
I wouldn't--
I think if you have
any kind of
substantial business,
I would encourage you
to kind of
check your own
privacy policy as well.
Shen: Okay,
let me just take one--
There's one question
on the Moderator tool.
I think it's probably
how [indistinct]
used OpenSocial
on his Web site,
probably like GFC.
You wanna say something
about GFC?
Trewhella: Yeah, so I mean
OpenSocial is more
about building an application
to put on a social network.
We have another product
called Friend Connect.
And there's some Friend Connect
dudes sitting right there.
Wave your hands
in the air.
Shen: The talk earlier
is Friend Connect.
Trewhella: And that's
the idea of taking people--
or taking the social graph
of an existing social network
and deploying it
onto your Web site.
There's a couple of ways
you can do that.
There's some cut and paste code,
so it's as simple as
putting a YouTube video onto
your Web site to integrate that.
But there's also
a much deeper integration.
You can start to talk
directly to the social sites
with [indistinct]
interfaces.
Kind of do a much
deeper-level integration.
These guys can
help out with that.
There was a talk
just before this
that if you check out on YouTube
tomorrow you can have a look.
And also
code.google.com/friendconnect.
Shen: We're running
a little late.
One more question
from Loren.
Loren: Hi.
Just a question about--
So it's been hammered into us
over the last two days,
look at metrics,
look at metrics.
So the quantitative part
is important.
But if I'm looking
at A/B testing, right?
And I look and I say
A has much better conversion,
but I really want B because
maybe it's a payment method
that's really,
really cheap,
and I'd like to ask questions
about why they chose A over B,
I can go to my community,
and that's good,
but is there some way,
in your experience,
when you guys have
worked with, you know,
either as the developer
advocates or as Myspace,
you've worked with people
that have been able
to somehow reach out to that
population that's chosen A
and been able to ask them
qualitative questions
in a light way where you get
a little more input about,
you know, having more control
over what happens
once you have that data?
Shen: Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely have a great point.
I always--
I mean, metric is one thing.
I always go with some anecdotes,
and to confirm the numbers,
because numbers--
they tell you the picture
maybe without
the story behind it.
But that's a great point.
You have anything to add?
Capiel: Yeah, I mean,
I know our best developers
definitely have, like,
a committee forums area
where they can actually
interact in a qualitative way
with users and kind of
learn those things,
so I think, you know,
you would be wise to kind of
make sure there's
an easy way for users
to contact you
and ask questions.
And that's a place where
you can engage
and kind of talk to them
and understand,
you know,
why something may work
and may not work for them
besides what
the numbers tell you.
Trewhella: One other thing
I'd add is that
because you're putting an
application on a social network,
you immediately know
who these people are, right?
So you can say, well,
we've got choice A and choice B,
90% of people
go for choice A,
let's look at
the 10% who chose B,
get their e-mail addresses,
and just say,
"Hey, why did you pick B?"
Shen: Great. Okay.
Since we're running over,
thank you again for coming,
and enjoy the lunch now.
Thank you.
[applause]